[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem True Crime Podcast
mein Name ist Mirko Casimir und an
meiner Seite ist die wunderbare Tony
Haie Halloween das ist aber eine schöne
Begrüßung hi grüß Dich Toni schön dass
du hier bist und eine Warnung vorab wir
erzählen heute von einem extrem brutalen
Mord dem eine ganze Familie Mutter Vater
und zwei kleine Kinder zum Opfer fallen
und wir können gut verstehen wenn ihr
das nicht hören wollt und diese Ausgabe
lieber überspringt wenn ihr noch da seid
dann nehmen wir euch jetzt mit nach
Japan in die Nacht vom 30 auf den 31
Dezember 2000 und in das Haus der
Familie miasa war
das kleine Haus steht beinahe einsam und
trotzig im Tokyoter Stadtteil setagaya
einst stand es unter Dutzenden in einem
lebendigen Viertel doch inzwischen wurde
die ganze Nachbarschaft bis auf vier
Häuser abgerissen um Platz für die
Erweiterung des benachbarten Sushi
galliaparks zu schaffen die Einwohner
wurden großzügig entschädigt bei einer
alle sind schon weggezogen auch die Mia
Savas haben die Entschädigung erhalten
aber noch keine neue Bleibe gefunden und
so harren die 41-Jährige jasuko der
44-Jährige mikino und ihre beiden Kinder
wie Ina und Rey 68 Jahre alt in dem
verlassenen Stadtviertel aus ganz allein
sind sie nicht im angrenzenden Haus
wohnt ihr so Großmutter Haruko und ganz
so verlassen und ruhig wie das jetzt
klingt ist die Gegend ohnehin nicht was
vor allem an dem ganz in der Nähe des
Hauses gelegenen Skateparks liegt
der Mörder kommt kurz vor Mitternacht
hinter dem Haus steht ein Baum den er
nutzt um in den zweiten Stock zu
klettern dort entfernt er das
Fliegengitter eines Fensters und
klettert ins Badezimmer sein erstes
Opfer wird der sechsjährige Ray sein
Schlafzimmer liegt direkt neben dem Bad
der Täter erwirkt den kleinen Jungen mit
bloßen Händen der Junge muss sich
gewährt oder noch geschrien haben denn
Vater mikio hört etwas und stürmt aus
dem Schlafzimmer im Dachgeschoss die
Treppe zum Kinderzimmer seines Sohnes
hinab sieht den Eindringling und greift
ihn an er kämpft um das Leben seines
Sohnes und sein eigenes vergebens der
Angreifer zieht ein langes schmales
Messer wie es normalerweise zur
Zubereitung von Sashimi also dünnen
Scheiben von rohem Fisch verwendet wird
trotzdem kann mich hier dem Täter eine
schwere Verletzung an der Hand
beibringen doch dann rammt ihm der
Mörder das Messer direkt in den Kopf mit
solcher Wucht und Grausamkeit dass die
Klinge bricht und ein Teil von ihr in
mikäus Schädel verbleibt dann stößt er
ihn die Treppe hinab ja super und Nina
müssen mit angehört vielleicht sogar
gesehen haben wie ihr Mann und Vater
getötet wird ein unvorstellbarer Horror
und sie sind im Dachgeschoss des Hauses
gefangen es gibt keinen Weg zu entkommen
in aller Ruhe geht der Mörder in die
Küche im Erdgeschoss sucht sich ein
neues Messer wieder ein Küchenmesser und
geht hinauf ins Dachgeschoss wo die
kleine Nina und ihre Mutter nichts
anderes tun können als ihren Mörder zu
erwarten
yasuku versucht ihre Tochter zu schützen
wirft sich auf sie doch die beiden haben
keine Chance er tötet sie mit mehreren
Messerstichen
[Musik]
was dann folgt gehört zu den bizarren
Details dieses Falls und brachte ihm den
Namen goldilocksmörder ein also die
Goldlöckchen Morde nach dem Märchen
Goldlöckchen und die drei Bären ein
englisches Märchen das unter anderem von
Walt Disney verfilmt in Deutschland aber
nie so richtig populär wurde es erinnert
stellenweise an Schneewittchen nur eben
mit drei Bären statt sieben Zwergen
[Musik]
die drei Bären wohnen zusammen in einem
Häuschen im Wald jeder von ihnen hat
sein eigenes Bett eine eigene Schüssel
für den Brei den sie so lieben und einen
eigenen Stuhl eines Tages während er
heißer Brei noch abkühlen muss machen
sie einen kleinen Spaziergang zur selben
Zeit wird ein Mädchen mit goldenem
lockigen Haar durch den Wald und stößt
auf das Haus der Bären sie ist den Brei
des ersten setzt sich auf den Stuhl des
zweiten der dabei zerbricht und legt
sich ins Bett des dritten zum Schlafen
dort finden die drei Bären sie
schließlich
aber was hat das noch mal mit unserem
Fall zu tun okay zurück zu unserem Fall
der Killer und Einbrecher bleibt nach
den Morden im Haus seiner Opfer und wie
Goldlöckchen und Schneewittchen bedient
er sich ohne zu zögern an dem was er
vorfindet der Täter bleibt mindestens
zwei möglicherweise bis zu zehn Stunden
am Tatort er verbindet die Wunde an der
Hand er ist Eis aus dem Kühlschrank der
Mia Sauers vier Sorten probierte aus er
trinkt gerstentee surft am Rechner der
Familie im Internet zieht sich Kleidung
des Vaters an und macht den Indizien
nach sogar ein Nickerchen auf dem Sofa
und er benutzt die Toilette für ein
großes Geschäft ohne zu spülen hmm
definitiv nicht Schneewittchen Style na
ja ich weiß nicht um das Thema wird hier
ein Märchenbücher normalerweise ein
großer Bogen
danke ich glaube wir brauchen das hier
nicht weiter vertiefen eins ist auf
jeden Fall klar der Mörder hinterlässt
unglaublich viele Beweisstücke am Tatort
Fingerabdrücke den ah die Tatwaffen
seine eigene Kleidung und ja die
Hinterlassenschaft im Badezimmer anhand
derer die Polizei später sogar sagen
kann was er vor der Tat alles gegessen
hat entdeckt werden die Leichen von
yasucos Mutter die sich im Nachbarhaus
warum ihre Tochter nicht ans Telefon
geht kurz nach 10 Uhr morgens am
31.12.2000 geht sie nach nebenan und
erlebt den wohl schlimmsten Albtraum den
man sich vorstellen kann im Erdgeschoss
am Fuß der Treppe liegt ihr
Schwiegersohn mit einer schrecklichen
Wunde am Kopf und mehreren weiteren
Verletzungen
Ray in seinem Bett erstickt ihre Tochter
leblos von zahlreichen Messerstichen
schrecklich zugerichtet und unter ihr
nie Ina die Enkelin eine ganze Familie
ihre Familie ausgelöscht
Werbung
Mirko ich muss dir was ein bisschen
peinliches erzählen kennst du das wenn
du auf der Speisekarte etwas liest und
die Beschreibung ist tausend Prozent das
worauf du Bock hast das Problem ist nur
es heißt irgendwas auf Französisch und
du hast keine Ahnung wie du es
aussprechen sollst absolut aus Angst aus
Angst aus Panik aus Scham habe ich es
dann nicht bestellt weil ich nicht
wusste wie man es ausspricht und ich mir
nicht die Blöße geben wollte und ich
habe gesagt es ist jetzt Schluss damit
das kann so nicht weitergehen ich gehe
das Thema jetzt an ich werde jetzt eine
Sprache lernen das ist eine super Idee
ich mache das ja genauso ja du weißt ich
über eine Schwäche für Südamerika und
ganz besonders liebe ich ja Kolumbien
der das sola hab leider den gelesen und
Herr Juda in kolumbia und mit Englisch
kommt man da nicht besonders weit ist es
sieht das April der espanol
tja und genau damit habe ich auch vor
ein paar Jahren angefangen aber du weißt
ja unser Job ist manchmal recht stressig
die Zeit wirklich knapp bemessen ja
definitiv und da kommt unser heutiger
Werbepartner Bubble wie gerufen das ist
eine preisgekrönte sprachlern-app mit
Sprachkursen für 14 Sprachen wie
Englisch Spanisch Italienisch
Französisch Portugiesisch Türkisch und
und und das Beste daran ist die
Lektionen behandeln alltagsrelevante
Themen und enthalten realistische
Dialoge ja und das bedeutet dass man das
Gelernte sofort im echten Leben anwenden
kann und das ist ja besonders jetzt im
Sommer interessant wenn Reisen auf dem
Plan stehen genau dann ist Babbel eine
unschätzbare Hilfe um sie auf alle
möglichen Situationen vorzubereiten wie
z.B im Restaurant zu bestellen
alle lernen Inhalte werden von dem Team
aus über 150 sprachexpertinnen erstellt
die Kurse sind individuell auf eure
Erstsprache sowie eure Lernziele
zugeschnitten sei es für den Beruf oder
eben für die Reise tja und das beste ist
das Babel für jedes Sprachlevel
verfügbar ist egal ob ihr Anfänger seid
oder schon fortgeschritten es ist
wirklich für jeden was dabei und die
Lektion dauern nur ungefähr 15 Minuten
egal wann das passt wirklich in jedem
Terminkalender egal ob ihr in der Bahn
unterwegs seid am Flughafen oder sonst
was wann und wo und wie oft ihr lernt
das entscheidet ihr selbst von Lektionen
über Podcasts Spiele bis hin zum
online-gruppenunterricht bei Babel könnt
ihr wirklich die Lernmethode finden die
zu euch passt die App hat auch eine
Spracherkennungssoftware
lernerinnerungen und viele weitere
hilfreiche Features damit ihr auch dran
bleibt ganz genau und damit könnt ihr
jetzt auch starten denn wir haben ein
ganz besonderes Angebot für euch denn
mit dem Code Tatort also großes T a t o
t könnt ihr ein Babbel Jahresabo zum
Preis von nur sechs Monaten erhalten
heißt für euch sechs Monate zahlen aber
ein ganzes Jahr lernen wichtiger Hinweis
noch der online-gruppenunterricht ist in
diesem Angebot nicht enthalten also wenn
ihr euer sprachabenteuer starten wollt
geht auf
bubble.com/audio und löst den Code bis
zum 31 Oktober 2023 ein alle Details
findet ihr auch in den Show notes
Werbung Ende
die Polizei ist zuversichtlich den Fall
schnell klären zu können denn anders als
bei anderen Fällen gibt es hier ja eine
überwältigende Menge an Beweismitteln
damit haben sie zwar noch keinen Täter
aber viele Hinweise auf seine Identität
seine Fingerabdrücke sind nicht in der
Polizei Datenbank er ist also entweder
nicht vorbestraft oder kein
Einheimischer die DNA-Analyse deutet
darauf hin dass seine Mutter
wahrscheinlich aus Südeuropa stammt oder
südeuropäische Vorfahren hat der Vater
ist möglicherweise Koreaner oder Chinese
die akrobatische Art des Einbruchs und
die Kämpfe deuten auf einen jungen Mann
hin Rechtshänder ungefähr einem Meter 70
groß schlank wie man anhand des Umfangs
der von ihm zurückgelassenen
Gürteltasche schlussfolgert überhaupt
sind die Gürteltasche und die blutige
Kleidung des Täters die wichtigsten
Hinweise
schnell führt eine Spur nach Südkorea
der Killer trug weiße Laufschuhe einer
Marke die zwar auch in Japan verbreitet
ist die jedoch nur in Korea in der Größe
verkauft wird die der Täter trug
zusammen mit der DNA die auf eine
koreanische Abstammung hindeuten könnte
klingt das vielversprechend doch die
Spur führt ins Leere in Südkorea werden
die Fingerabdrücke aller Einwohner
gesammelt und gespeichert unabhängig
davon ob sie jemals mit der Polizei in
Berührung geraten sind oder nicht die
Abdrücke des Täters sind nicht dabei
auch eine weitere Spur verläuft im Sand
der Täter trug ein weißes Shirt mit
violetten Ärmeln von dem in ganz Japan
nur 130 Stück verkauft wurden mit großem
Aufwand versucht die Polizei die Käufer
aufzuspüren doch sie findet nur ein
gutes Dutzend die sich alle schnell als
unschuldig erweisen es gibt auch äußerst
verwirrende Hinweise in der Gürteltasche
werden Sandkörner gefunden und nach
einer langwierigen und aufwendigen
Untersuchung kann ihre wahrscheinliche
Herkunft ermittelt werden sie scheinen
aus dem Südwesten der USA zustammen aus
der Wüste von Nevada aus einem Gebiet
nahe der Edwards Air Force Base
es wird eine der größten Ermittlungen
der japanischen Kriminalgeschichte und
ich finde man könnte fast behaupten der
weltweiten Kriminalgeschichte über die
Jahre arbeiten haltet euch fest
264.044 Ermittler an diesem Fall das ist
echt eine Hausnummer ja das mag
unglaubwürdig klingen aber wir haben das
wirklich sich mal überprüft weil wir
selber nicht glauben konnten aber diese
Zahl taucht überall auf manchmal mit
kleineren Abweichungen aber man muss
natürlich dazu sagen dass die nicht alle
gleichzeitig an diesem Fall gearbeitet
haben denn dieser Fall ist bis heute
nicht gelöst und auch bis heute gibt es
doch Ermittler die ausschließlich nur
mit diesem Fall beschäftigt sind ja aber
trotzdem 264
000 und 44 also selbst in den mehr als
20 Jahren seit den Morden können doch
nicht eine vierte Millionen Japanerin
und Japaner bei der Mordkommission
gearbeitet haben ja ich nehme an dass
sie auch jeden Streifenbeamten oder
jeden Beamten der in irgendeiner Art und
Weise an diesem Fall beteiligt waren sei
es nur dass er die Umgebung nach Spuren
abgesucht hat auch die als Ermittler
mitgezählt haben und sicher auch die
Kollegen in Korea und Nevada ja das mag
sein also eine viertel Millionen Leute
auf der Suche nach einem Mörder
unterstützt von ganz Japan und mehr als
20 Jahre dabei ist nicht ein ernsthafter
Verdächtiger bei rausgekommen naja es
gibt einen erinnert ihr euch das Haus
der mir Savas liegt in der Nähe eines
Skateparks der darf eigentlich nur
tagsüber genutzt werden doch da er seit
dem Abriss der meisten Häuser in der
Gegend so scheinbar abseits von allem
liegt ist er beliebt bei skeltern aus
ganz Tokio und der Umgebung die hier bis
spät in die Nacht skaten und Feiern ja
aber da sind ja noch Anwohner mikio Mia
Sava hat sich mehrmals über den Lärm
beschwert bei den Behörden und bei den
Skaten mit einem von ihm ist er
anscheinend ernsthaft aneinander geraten
könnte es sein dass jemand aus Wut über
eine lärmbeschwerde eine ganze Familie
ermordet hat dazu passt dass die
Kleidung die der Täter zurückgelassen
hat gut zu einem Skater passen würde
schnell gerät ein junger Mann in sich
sehr der Ermittler
und wird ebenso schnell entlastet
zumindest dazu sind die Beweisstücke die
Ideen a die Fingerabdrücke gut um
Verdächtige auszuschließen bei einem so
abscheulichen und rätselhaften
Verbrechen und bei einem derart krassen
ungewöhnlichen Verhalten des Mörders
nach der Tat gibt es natürlich jede
Menge Theorien eine der weniger wilden
und spekulativen geht von einem Raubmord
aus und tatsächlich wurde Geld aus dem
Haus gestohlen vielleicht wollte der
Täter nur einweichen doch der kleine Reh
wurde wach und bemerkte ihn der Täter
stürzte sich auf ihn um den Zeugen zu
beseitigen der Vater kommt hinzu stürzt
sich auf ihn um seinen Sohn zu schützen
und nachdem er den Vater getötet hat
meint er keine andere Wahl mehr zu haben
als auch die anderen Zeuginnen zum
Schweigen zu bringen aber wenn er die
Familie aus Angst vor Entdeckung tötet
warum lässt er dann diesen Haufen an
Beweisstücken zurück Toni Haufen klingt
in diesem zusammen wirklich ziemlich
zweideutig sagen wir mal so diese Menge
und überhaupt welcher Räuber machte sich
im Haus seine Opfer noch bequem nachdem
er sie getötet hat es stimmt zwar dass
er offenbar Geld gestohlen hat aber der
größte Teil des Geldes der Familie der
blieb unberührt eine andere Theorie
besagt dass ein Auftragsmörder auf die
Familie eingesetzt wurde weil ein sehr
großer Geldbetrag im Haus vermutet wurde
vielleicht die Entschädigungszahlung für
den anstehenden Abriss des Hauses aber
auch das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn
ein Auftragsmörder ein Profi das ist
doch der letzte der einen solchen
chaotischen Tatort hinterlassen würde
und dann ist da noch die Geschichte von
einem Kampfpiloten der aus welchen
Gründen auch immer die Familie getötet
haben soll diese Theorie ruht auf den
Sandkörnern die aus den USA und aus der
Umgebung einer Air Force Base stammen
könnten auf die er auch schon Piloten
aus Japan und Südkorea aus gebildet
wurden ja aber all das bleibt
substanzlos alles führt in die Sackgasse
kriminalpsychologinnen haben vermutet
dass der Täter bereits vorher gemordet
hat oder danach wieder morgen würde
jemand der so kaltblütig und brutal
vorgeht und der in der Lage ist
hinterher das Eis der Kinder der gerade
erst ermordet hat zu essen der genießt
was er tut und er wird es wieder tun
alles Spekulation aber sehr beunruhigend
denn vermutlich ist der Täter noch am
Leben auf Hinweise sind 2 Millionen Yen
ausgesetzt das sind umgerechnet etwa
125.000 Euro dann hoffen wir dass er
irgendwann einkassiert wird
für unseren heutigen Fall der
Goldlöckchen Morde haben wir unter
anderem auf Artikel von buzzfeed
nike.com und der South China morning
Post zurückgegriffen sie empfehlen könnt
ihr euch auch den allerdings
englischsprachigen Podcast faceless des
Krimiautoren und Journalisten Nick Oper
der in insgesamt acht Folgen alle
möglichen Details und Theorien zu den
Morden unter die Lupe nimmt das war's
für heute von uns danke dass er wieder
mit dabei wart und ich hoffe dass sie
auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit
einschaltet eure Toni und euer Mirko